-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy-nominated co-head writer
of "Saturday Night Live."
All episodes of his new show
"That Damn Michael Che,"
are available to stream
this Thursday on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-I just want to say I'm sorry.
-Oh, it's cool.
I could barely smell it.
-W-- Oh, no, not that.
I mean I'm sorry for everythin
going on in the country.
[ Suspenseful music plays
With the police shootings
and all the injustices
and for white privilege.
-This thing even move yet?
-Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
Michael Che.
♪♪♪♪
-Hi.
-Isn't this something?
Isn't this great?
-This is good.
This is good. Oh!
-Welcome, buddy.
-How are you?
-I mean, you've done a coupl
of these with no audiences
-Yes, I have.
-How is it --
I know it's not full at "SNL,"
but it really does feel full
at home watching.
-It feels amazing now.
Like, it feels really,
really great.
Like, I don't know
how many people's in there
but you start to forget what
it was like when it was packed
-Right. You just needed to set
a new baseline, and now --
-Yeah, and it's also
kind of cool
because you can hear, like
you know, specific things,
like, "That wasn't funny."
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, it's nice.
Sometimes when it gets too full,
you can't hear, like,
specific in-the-moment notes
-I remember me and Jost
did Mania,
and it was in MetLife Stadium.
And it was like 80,000,
90,000 people,
this big wrestling event.
And we went out, and you
just hear the roar of boos
which we're used to.
But then if you made eye contact
with somebody,
you can hear specifically
what they were saying about you,
what they hated about you,
and that was a lot more intense.
-The best one
that ever happened to me
was when I was doing "Update."
My parents were in the audience.
And I told one joke
that bombed with everyone,
except my mom
laughed really loud.
And I got -- My brother wrote me
an e-mail the next day
that said, "Well, Mom liked it."
-[ Laughs ]
That's great.
We did one I think
like two weeks ago.
I don't even -- if it was my
joke or if it was Colin's joke
But one lady just said, "No.
Like, no? What do you mean, no
That's not an option.
-I've talked
to some people who --
It was more before
it got too cold to do it,
people that were doing outdoor
shows, maybe like September.
And they were saying, one,
they had to remember
how to be a stand-up again
but they also
felt like the audience
had to remember
how to be audiences again.
-Yeah, I mean, stand-up's a lo
harder than being an audience.
I think it's probably
harder for them
because you're not being
very funny onstage, you know
'Cause stand-up is a lot
about just remembering
and timing and all of that
And when you don't have that
it does look like
a guy just talking,
which is something
nobody really wants.
-Right, everybody wants to d
but nobody wants to watch.
-Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
-Yeah, people are like, "Oh,
my God, I'd love a microphon
and be allowed to talk
for an hour."
It has been --
You have three shows left.
-Yes.
-A weird season.
-An incredible accomplishmen
that you guys got --
you're gonna get through it,
knock on wood.
-I mean, we've had some really
really cool guests.
We had Chappelle.
We had Burr.
We had Daniel Kaluuya.
We had Issa Rae.
We had Regina King.
Like, we had an amazing season
of guests, I think.
-And now Elon Musk
is gonna be on.
-Yeah, you know,
that's gonna be exciting, too.
He's the richest man
in the world.
How could you not be excited
for that?
-Do you have any interest --
You know, I will say,
talking about stand-ups,
'cause I think that...
Obama very much had
a stand-up cadence, I thought.
And then I think that Trum
sort of had stand-up material.
He was, like, working on an act.
-That's the best way
I've ever heard it put.
Obama has the cadence,
and Trump has the material
-He's just been working at -
And one of the funniest
where I was genuinely like, "Oh,
that's a good stand-up bit,"
is he used to talk about how all
rich people want to go to space.
And I was like, "Oh,
that's a pretty good premise
for a stand-up bit."
-It's really good.
It's very rich.
Can we laugh at him now?
-Who, Trump?
-Yeah, can we laugh with him
-Oh, can we laugh with him
-Different question.
-When are we allowed
to laugh with him again?
to laugh with Trump
and say, "You know what?
That one was really funny.
-Do you have any interest
in going to space?
-I mean, not first.
[ Laughter ]
Not first.
I didn't want to be first
to get the vaccine, man.
We're very paranoid people
-Yeah.
Well, I mean, I think -- Yeah.
If Elon said, though, if he wa
going and he invited you to go
-He'd have to FaceTime me
from there.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-And I'd have to be certai
that he was actually there
I don't know if you're
a history buff,
but we've been tricked before.
-[ Laughs ]
A very funny clip
with you and Cecily.
I've only watched
the first episode,
which I was telling you
backstage I think is great
It will come to no surpris
to anyone who knows
the way you write
and the way you do stand-up,
this show is not entirely,
but a good deal about race
-Yes.
-And the thing I cannot fathom
and I've talked to you
about this, as well,
is that you basically wrot
and did this show
while you were doing "SNL,
which just seems overwhelming.
-It was a very bad idea,
as they say in the business.
It was exhausting, man.
This was, like, a really,
really exhausting year
of doing this show.
We not only wrote it, but we
also shot it during "SNL."
So, like, on off weeks,
we would just be doing that.
So this is kind of like --
This next break that we have
for the season
will be, like, kind of my firs
actual break from anything
And then I'll just be
doing stand-up.
-Are you glad that they're all
coming out at once?
Because it must be strange
to write sketches at "SNL,
which you never have to wait
more than basically five day
until you see it.
I mean, at first,
initially I wasn't.
Initially I wanted to roll out
like "SNL"
because then you could
always improve it.
But now I'm like, "Oh, yeah,
it'd be either one week
of great press
or one week of terrible press,
and then it's over,"
and I kind of like that they'r
all kind of coming out.
You can watch it
at your own leisure.
-I want to -- have
a lot more questions for you
but particularly
about the title.
We'll be right back with mor
from Michael Che.